[Música]
tentacular y fascinante bombay la
capital económica de India ha visto en
los últimos años uno de los más grandes
crecimientos demográficos del país
más de 8 millones de habitantes en 30
años como si toda la ciudad de Nueva
York hubiera ocupado este lugar como
resultado el tráfico aumenta la
contaminación estalla y el acceso al
agua potable hace falta
[Música]
en bombay a medida que la población
crece los precios de los inmuebles se
incrementan a causa de una fuerte
demanda en ciertos barrios los precios
alcanzan los Diez mil euros por metro
cuadrado como en París mientras que los
más pobres la tienen más difícil para
encontrar alojamiento
hace un 52 años este trabajador social
vive con toda su familia en 14 metros
cuadrados
Esta es mi casa aquí vivimos ocho
personas mi madre mi esposa mi hermano
mi hermana su hijo y mis dos hijos y yo
una sola habitación está conectada con
una cocina minúscula y una sola ducha
los baños son compartidos con los otros
habitantes del inmueble
para dormir debemos arreglarnoslas Mi
madre duerme en la cama y nosotros
dormimos en el suelo unos al lado de los
otros quisiéramos mudarnos pero no
tenemos los medios para comprar ni para
pagar una arriendo
en la ciudad la presión sobre el mercado
inmobiliario es tal que incluso la clase
media tiene dificultades para encontrar
vivienda en el corazón de los suburbios
viven ahora ingenieros profesores
comerciantes
Raúl yadua es contable gana mil euros al
mes un buen salario en la India pero que
no le permite abandonar el barrio donde
creció
Este es mi hogar para él es imposible
comprar lo único que podría permitirse
era esta casa de ladrillo cada vez con
más frecuencia sustituye las casas de
Hojalata en los barrios de suburbios
no hay sitio para los más pobres ni para
la clase media dicen que en bombay
puedes alimentarte puedes trabajar pero
no puedes conseguir un lugar donde vivir
a pesar de la existencia de un plan
nacional que promete viviendas decentes
para los más desfavorecidos en bombay
sigue aumentando el número de viviendas
improvisadas casi una de cada dos
personas vive aquí en un barrio marginal